[Musique]
on
assange martel vétéran de la guerre de
corée
[Musique]
je suis à rodez l'a 10 à 5 ans a déjà
commencé depuis ça va mieux pour lavage
ou du 7ème art en jeu de nadal mais mon
père me dit attendons land art mélo qui
est trop jeune pour travailler mais je
souhaitais dixième année parce que lui
avait été en aviation à ias 39 45
je dois revenir au bout tout rose un peu
différente un peu plus vieux de 3 savoir
mieux quoi fin dans ta vie
il en allait toucher tout le monde lors
des quelques heures plus tard le camion
devait arriver nous allons savoir si
telle montagne non seulement de bixi est
abonné
nous avons aussi pas à vendre sa beauté
d'avril ou pas dangereux
on ne sait pas
nous on oublie ça désordre fier dit
saouad up face aux grosses stars
kassav en battant à map genève
après quelques jours d'avoir balle de
match
[Musique]
quelqu'un et amant puis en prenant du
fils de téléphone et quand officielle
des jambes des broches à bordeaux prime
à la cuve en parallèle et à wages se
sentait que quand façon les premières
fois au bon grain
la peur commence à s'en aller
tranquillement c'est pas juste la peur
de mourir
titubant bondi ce programme c'est d'être
blessé sévèrement
c'est la fin
[Musique]
une partie de mon temps à coller ça ma
voiture et les blessés mais des
rencontres meetic a dit ouais c'est ça
des fois qu'ils battent
il avait du stress dans un moment ça
s'appelait pascal quint qui savent à peu
aux as un peu aux trois ponts sud
malaisie saut pour l'ameublement qui
amène de daytona moubarak raison parce
que les opposants je n'en parle même pas
que ma femme
[Musique]
et en 2007 2013 non je retourne à
facebook
au moins la première fois en presque pas
de brouiller tourner tant que tel
un sentiment de pitié ou en même temps
de de faiblesse sédatifs au niveau
puisque la g
je voyais les deux brises dans la plaine
a fait tuer des milliers de personnes
bien connues ici paris plus d'un million
de familles aux dents longues sont
nourris qui ont des parents à quoi des
météores à mary n'ont jamais connu
d'autre aux autres la dictature c'est
pointer ses du pouvoir
[Musique]
on est bien aujourd'hui un duo canadien
encana presse à la haye on vit dans un
pays où il n'ya pas de dire tant
attendue vers la fin de mon choix
poursuit mme acker jours
[Musique]